millions under state of emergency in the
central us after a deadly storm
triggered massive flooding severe
thunderstorms also pounded parts of
western Pennsylvania and New York State
downpours flooded streets and high winds
toppled trees the storm system began
this weekend and exploded over the
plains with torrential rain tornadoes
and even snow in the month of May at
least 16 people were killed there dozens
more were hurt this morning flood
warnings cover most of the state of
Missouri
Michelle Millers in Pacific that's
outside st. Louis were overnight flood
waters from the Merrimack River was part
of a major interstate Michelle good
morning to you good morning the
Merrimack River is just a half mile
behind me but to give you an idea of
just how fast these waters have risen
right about here as of two hours ago was
dry land now people all along this river
have been evacuated and these rising
waters continue to threaten homes and
businesses three days of heavy downpours
have inundated rivers across Missouri
forcing floodwaters to spill into cities
across highways and through backyards
volunteers including governor Eric
Greitens have been scrambling to prepare
for the rising water when we were warned
that this weather was coming we
proactively went out declared a state of
emergency which allowed us to position
swift water rescue teams around the
state those teams have conducted
hundreds of operations literally saved
hundreds of lives state officials have
shut down dozens of roads and bridges
threatened by the flooding currents were
so powerful along the Merrimack River
near st. Louis this entire steel bridge
was swept away images taken before and
after the flooding throughout the state
show the devastating impact happened so
fast once that once the water stopped
coming in under the doors I don't know
if it was 15 20 minutes and it was
thigh-high in the house
in Arkansas a two-day search for two
young children switch from a rescue to a
recovery effort the pair were swept away
from their mother and floodwaters on
Saturday bringing their grandfather to
tears
pull my heart up the Merrimack River is
expected to crest near record levels
tomorrow morning and more rain is due
Wednesday which could increase the
possibility of flash flooding charlie
Michelle thank you so much